well another day and another major
legislative accomplishment for joe biden
whose presidency in the last two months
as i told you about yesterday and the
day before
has really turned itself around the
inflation reduction act has now been
signed into law by president joe biden
this bill you might recall
barely passed the u.s senate 5150 but
sir how could it add up to 101 votes
well it was 50 50 with kamala harris as
vice president is the president of the
senate casting the tie-breaking vote 51
that was on august 7th there were no
republican votes we also saw the bill on
friday past the u.s house not
particularly widely by a 220 to 207
margin and joe biden has now signed the
bill into law and it is indeed major
major legislation let's take a look at
what this bill does it is a more than
430 billion dollar package expected to
reduce the deficit by over 300 billion
dollars over 10 years
it's expected to raise
737 billion dollars in revenue over 10
years and it includes 369 billion in
investment money for climate and energy
policy
64 billion dollars to extend the
affordable care act policy that reduces
health insurance costs so to be more
honest sometimes what it what we can
maybe more accurately say is it slows
down the rate of increase for health
insurance costs it includes importantly
notably a 15 percent corporate minimum
tax for companies earning over a billion
dollars a year this is a subject of much
discussion
which is
for individuals there has been an
alternative minimum tax for a long time
and the concept of an alternative
minimum tax is you make a million
dollars personally
you can use deductions and losses and
all these different things
to offset the full million in taxes and
you end up owing zero in order to
prevent that something called the
alternative minimum tax was established
which says that for a certain level of
income no matter how many deductions and
losses you have to offset taxable income
you have to pay some minimum tax we
never had that for corporations this
bill puts that in place at a 15 percent
rate it also puts in place a one percent
tax on stock buybacks done by large
corporations this was something that was
a big deal during the pandemic you may
recall
uh when the donald trump uh coronavirus
stimuli packages were
enacted
many corporations from the um corporate
side of it
used the money they got
to just buy back their own stock raising
its price so this bill puts in place a
one percent tax when you do stock
buybacks it will reduce drug prices for
medicare recipients uh it will it
expects to collect an additional 124
billion dollars from increased irs
enforcement so there's money in the bill
controversially so for many to hire more
irs agents the belief is that those
additional agents are going to find tax
cheats and recover 124 billion
additional dollars it includes tax
credits to incentivize electric cars and
electric hvac systems as well as other
forms of cleaner technology that's great
and it is expected to cut pollution by
around 40 percent below the 2005 level
by 2030
and it also puts in place a 2 000 a year
out-of-pocket cap
for medicare recipients now a few
thoughts on this number one
is this a major legislative
accomplishment for joe biden yes it is
will people vote based on this in
november it's not totally clear
um
we'll see what polling suggests over the
next probably two to three weeks
regardless of your political persuasion
there are things in this that are
beneficial to most of the americans uh
in the country
for example the two thousand dollar
out-of-pocket cap for medicare
recipients medicare recipients are both
democrats and republicans in fact
we it's a more conservative group we
know that every older cohort is slightly
more conservative in the united states
right now
less pollution is everybody benefits
from less pollution even if you're
against
green energy or whatever um all there
are things in here from which everyone
benefits regardless of political
persuasion now i want to
take a sort of political
overview of the biden administration
generally
my philosophy
is generally speaking to judge
presidents by what they do more than by
what they don't do now there are
exceptions to that for example
donald trump failed to do many things in
terms of his covet response
that is an area where you have an acute
situation
and it seems logical to say look all
these other world leaders did these
things trump failed to do that that was
an acute thing but there are people who
wrote to me over the last 12 to 24 hours
about the inflation reduction act saying
david this is not good for biden what we
need to be focusing on with biden is he
hasn't decriminalized marijuana
he hasn't forgiven all student debt by
the way joe biden did forgive a bunch
more student debt overnight and we'll
talk about that on the bonus show joe
biden did not do xyz
right
trump also didn't decriminalize
marijuana obama didn't decriminalize
marijuana it seems to me if we're trying
to evaluate a president's performance
none of them decriminalize marijuana and
it sort of zeros out i want cannabis
decriminalized to be clear but it seems
weird to me to react to what is clearly
a major legislative accomplishment and
to say well biden hasn't done this other
thing i tend to judge presidents by the
things that they do
and this is a very good thing this
should be screamed from the rooftops on
media social media etc by democrats and
remind people you all benefit from
things in this bill even though every
republican in the senate voted against
it so are there things joe biden uh has
not done that i would like to see him do
absolutely have i been critical of joe
biden's lack of accomplishments i have
100
but this is an accomplishment the jobs
numbers are good the economy is looking
very good inflation's coming down the
packed act has been signed for people
that think this type of thing is good he
has gone and uh he approved the strike
that killed al-qaeda terrorist ayman
al-zawahiri many of you have concerns
about due process i share those concerns
these are the things he has done
and it makes absolute and perfect sense
for to give him credit for those and
then compare to the alternative when it
comes time if he runs for re-election
what would this other person who is
eventually going to be the republican
nominee what would they have done in
this situation they wouldn't have passed
the inflation reduction act they likely
would not have passed the pact act they
wouldn't have done a lot of the things
joe biden did that are good and then we
evaluate well is it worthy of reelection
that's a question for down down the road
we don't even know if biden is running
our show has many sponsors i love them
all but there's one product i use more
than any other because i sit on it every
day and that's my all form sofa in my
living room i've had this for three
years now it still looks amazing all
form is the easiest way by far to design
your own custom sofa because unlike with
other companies all form lets you choose
the fabric the size the shape the color
the color of the legs if you're spending
money on a sofa you should be able to
customize every single aspect of what
you want get exactly what you need
another unique thing about all form the
furniture is modular so you can buy one
piece and add to it later rearrange the
pieces this has so many advantages if
you move if you want to adapt the sofa
to a new space shipping is always fast
and free you've got 100 days to send it
back if you don't love it they all come
with a forever warranty and you'll get
20 percent off at all form dot com slash
pacman the link is down below